foreign
Champion Jensen battist
s
[Music]
your turn
no way and the Radford racing team teach
me how to drive like a maniac safe
kind of this is one hell of a video one
because you'll definitely learn more
than a thing or two and two because For
the First Time I didn't edit this video
it was all done remotely through canva
who are the sponsors of this video and
who have taken the collaboration game to
an entirely new level I will show you
how I do this all later but for now
traffic ever since I moved to LA I've
spent more time in traffic than I do
sleeping editing videos and surfing
combined all I can think about when my
mind drifts away is what it would be
like to drive like a complete madman how
they drive in car chase scenes and
movies or more specifically like Ansel
elgart and baby driver
[Music]
but what if I could so I said [ __ ] it I
packed all my bags and flew to Phoenix
Arizona to meet up with Jensen Batson at
the Radford race School race track
Jensen then took me around the racetrack
so fast I felt like my eyes were gonna
start bleeding
to Danny
ass and trains all the famous performers
to drive like controlled nutcases in
their movies to train me how to drive
like baby driver so that I could then
fly back to Los Angeles and create the
intro scene
foreign
[Music]
do you think I'll be able to do that
you'll definitely be able to accomplish
this like that and then keep going like
that okay perfect well have you roll on
big ass accelerate going backwards and
once you get up to enough speed you
don't have you with the steering wheel
around and that's going to push the back
end off to the side now as you get
around to your halfway point you're
about 90 degrees your eyes are now going
to start looking this way yeah and
you're going to whip the wheel the other
way back to straight okay and then all
you'll do after that is simply
accelerate out it's going to take me
like quite a few times and then we can
shoot it I reckon oh yeah
so what we'll do is we'll start off with
just putting the car in Reverse put your
left hand over five o'clock okay now
I'll check my mirrors for clearance make
sure no one's behind me we can't see
that GoPros here we've retained we've
retained yes
[Music]
reverse to forward it doesn't sound
complicated at all
okay cars in Reverse yes I roll onto the
gas nice and easy at first I don't get a
lot of wheel spin yeah one one thousand
two one thousand three one thousand off
the gas
[Applause]
so what we're gonna do next is I'm gonna
have you try it
okay I got it there's no way I can roll
the car no so I just send it just send
it okay
okay it's my turn
it's hot in Arizona
[Music]
I think we did hit it okay I'm gonna
need it I need to replace this for you
all right well we'll worry about that
later cool
here we go
I got it
floor it one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand left look
yes
you did it that was a fantabulous job
yeah before jumping on the plane back to
LA to do the stunts I wanted to get
ahead with the edit I opened up canva's
brief in the sky Gary who's in South
Africa which is nine hours ahead of La
this makes it really tough but my
favorite feature on canva whiteboards
make it super easy to collaborate
seamlessly to plan your shots as well as
give concise feedback while you're going
what's really rad is I can also video
myself talking through the points so
there's no broken telephone while
explaining something in detail you
should definitely join canva Pro today
because it's free for 45 days by using
the link in my description below Gary
would then get it when he woke up in
South Africa and immediately crack on
with the edit right Gary yeah when I got
back to LA with his Newfound Knowledge
from Danny and Jensen it was now time to
send it so I got two hyper realistic
Firearms a duffel bag stacks of cash
three black sunglasses two skull masks
corded headphones and a fast red car
foreign
you see for a beginner like me it'll be
far easier if I had a rear-wheel drive
vehicle however this car is a front
wheel drive
this is gonna be tricky furthermore I
organized this secure parking lot to do
the Stanton and ask two of my mates Ryan
and Connor to be bank robbers for the
day
oh [ __ ] I think my headphones got stuck
my bad exactly we got this car from our
friend and not tour one of our good
friend a good friend he's he's looking
that way towards the door
[Music]
it's good that looks scary see you guys
are running out of this story you guys
running do you like suck back like that
we've got an hour left of light
and we still need to do all these shots
[Music]
filmmaking that over there is gonna be
like the bank Ryan and Connor behind
camera yeah
something cool
in baby driver they rob a bank in Danny
driver
that's so stupid okay I'm gonna stick
with it there in Danny driver we are
robbing a restaurant I'm in reverse
Jason
oh and when Connor's in the shot this is
our other cameraman steadiest hands
we're running out of time we got like 20
minutes before the sun goes down
[Music]
laughs
what did I hit that was the gearbox you
can't you can't actually change okay on
to the final shot this is the main shot
and this parking lot that we're in isn't
very wide so
[ __ ] sorry cool I'm ready to show you
the scene but before I do I just want to
tell you more about the sponsor of this
video canva honestly this was the first
time I've ever used camper I'm just one
of those people that are super afraid to
try anything new but once I actually
opened it I couldn't stop playing around
the new features are endless and for me
it's a collaborative side of things the
seamless communication to stay
constantly up to date with your team no
matter where in the world they are it's
also fun and it's colorful and it
doesn't feel serious and there also so
many hidden doors there's so many new
things that I keep finding like being
able to manage all your social media
posts in one place with all their design
tools as well as being able to crop them
to the right size for each platform and
then it will automatically post for you
at the time you choose as well as of
course creating unique super
professional looking presentations with
a few clicks this really gives me the
confidence I need when pitching
something to a client okay cool back to
the video
he has a scene I hope you enjoy
[Music]
it took so much work just to capture
those few seconds but that's what
filmmaking is all about for me the
process learning new [ __ ] pushing the
boundaries and making lifelong friends a
huge thank you to Radford for having me
you guys are legends rolling
yeah that's it for this week's video
turn on your notifications Bell you got
to turn it on so you get notified
to uh
subscribe and comment below letting me
know what you thought of this video as
well as if there are any other scenes
from movies that you would like me to
recreate other than that don't forget
you're awesome bro and I'll see you next
week
[Music]